[Music]
good morning everyone welcome to the
Pandora and composer session it's not a
music session Saturday that you will
probably learn how you know composer
house Pandora to manage their music data
so I'm phone I'm a software engineer in
Google Cloud was a joining me today
Daniel from Pandora and Wilson -
formerly composer team so what started
talk by giving folks an overview of you
know what is the clock composer what
kind of problem was trying to solve and
you know what are some of the features
in composer and they were followed by
Danny on stage talking about the
pandora's experience of migrating their
work fluctuation to Google Cloud and
will wrap up the talk by some of the
newer and the latest features that were
just recently released so we live in an
increasingly complex world in the
context of data analytics this means you
know your data probably live in many
different places and every once awhile
there will be new data policies and
framework that get announced and maybe
once you're done with your data
processing you know there might be
different places so you need to sort of
upload your data processing results
eventually realized that you know it's
very unlikely that you can finish all
your data processing needs in a single
system it's very common that you have to
stitch you know data processing drops in
different systems together and
essentially put them in a form of a
workflow and once you have a workflow
and then you know ultimately comes the
need of like you know you want to be
able to schedule that workflow you want
to monitor a folk workflow really you
know think about the only way or like a
way to help you to reduce complexity
it's for automation and here it's really
important that you have a tool that
could upload and manage all this like
complexity of scattering
and monitoring workflows on your behalf
with that purpose in mind we design and
develop a composer it's built on top of
the popular open source Apache el flow
and that helps you to create workflows
at ease make it powerful for you to
manage your workflows so exactly how
does composer helps you to sort of
reduce your workflow management
complexities and help you to improve
your workflow development we focus on
few areas
I mean namely the first one is really
about you know we want to make sure
composer being the orchestration choice
when it comes to GCP so what that means
is we want to make sure that you know
from cloud composer you could
orchestrate and manage pretty much all
your GCP related workloads let it be a
mail jobs data flow data Park jobs
second thing as I mentioned earlier we
realized that the need that you know
today your data is likely going to leave
him different places on prime and
uncloudy so we design composer on day
one with that was that requirement that
you know whatever orchestration solution
could introduce that needs to work well
in a hybrid cloud environment also you
know be able to come out with higher
abstractions and also make it really
easy for you to write your workflow
especially I think about if you workflow
has you know tens or like hundreds or
thousands of tasks again we wanted to
make it really easy for you to be able
to act surprised workflows consist of
that many of tasks finally you know to
increase reuse finicky because you know
you have done all your development on
prime we don't want to be the case that
when you when you move to Google Cloud
and you realize oh now I need to read
divide put all my workflows so we really
put open-source in a core of clock
composer
and we make sure that you know what do I
have a workflow so you rewrite your
develop those can run in GCP and then
likewise when you move
certain workflows to run prime you find
out you don't have to modify anything
things should just work out of the box
so with those requirements in mind and
then we added a lot more sort of we
started develop design department of
call composer and then one of the
questions we often god was you know how
does it composer differentiate with a
self-managed Apache elf law I mean I
understand a problem and if you have a
none prime air flow deployments and
you're trying to wondering you know what
are some of the value-added pieces if I
move to call composer
they're quite some of those I'm going to
probably highlight a few important ones
the first one is really about you know a
lot of those are really sort of centered
around some price simplicity and also
trying to help you to minimize your
operational complexities so we have like
really convenient tooling you know cloud
console API and a G cloud for you to
manage your cloud l flowy excuse me a
clock composing environment and make it
easy for you to you know upload your
workflow and in spec workflow status
second thing you know probably like 70
to 80 percent of people rely on the L
fluid UI and also frankly speaking
that's also one of the distinctive
distinct factors that your people to
Apache L flow so we understand the need
that's why we put a lot of thoughts on
the to make things easier for you to
host your Apache on flow web server and
also make it extremely secure through
our cloud at an at an idea while proxy
and then when it comes to you know our
flow has different versions you know
people some people choose to you you
know there's also like a different PI
some versions as I since alpha is
developing in Python so again in call
composure really happy to streamline and
simplify the management of Python and
out flow versions so that you know in
Composer you can specify and in which
Python airflow brush you want to use and
it was to open the paths for you to sort
of like you know upgrade from one
flow to a different health inversion
given that you know often the case that
when you write your workflow you realize
that you may have external library
dependencies you may have customized
operators so that's why we will also
make it extremely simple for you to
install and manage additional pi PI
dependencies debugging and monitoring a
common needs these days you know what
have you work love failures so composer
comes out of box with stackdriver
logging in the monitoring integration so
whenever you have issues regarding to a
particular task you will be able to find
all the locks in stackdriver and finally
you know there are our IMS for you to
sort of streamline your composing
environment and manage permissions who
has access to what we launched the clock
composer last year during Google next
it's probably about being it has
probably been about nine months and
since then we add a lot more GC
operatives that's that's really why I
want to hide out here as you can see
from the slide pretty much we support
all the bulk of GC operators you know
you have mission Cloud a I translated
cultivation kubernetes on the data side
you have called sequel BigTable she says
ant spanner so those are all really
trying to make it easier for you to
write workflows so you don't really have
to worry about how should I interact
with these new systems I also want to as
I mention that you know writing
workflows are easy should and you know
and L flow has a very expressive
mechanism for you to express the your
workflow so your next couple of slides I
just want to show you a quick overview
of how a dag when workflow is developing
composure while flow so a little context
of history of a partial flow it's a
project that was originally developed by
Airbnb and subsequently got donated to
Apache Software Foundation and assist in
asking a lot of popularity in the
community it's a very very active
community has like a few hundred sort of
the contributors workflows are ascension
XPrize as directly a circular graph
that's why you probably have you know
for people coming from the elf flow
community you pop never hear heard them
talking a lot about DAGs
that's really essential workflows this
is a simple this is an example dag of
how you know kind of like a hollow word
ish workflow it has about a three tasks
and then you know you run different
commands and then you have ways to sort
of i specify the dependency among your
tasks at the beginning you do your
standard impart the like standard Python
imports those really just tell I all
flow hey I want to like the daj and the
tag is the workflow top-level workflow
construct and after that it just import
whatever operators your things are
useful you know in this case we use
Bachelor operator but you know they are
a paisa operator and then there's a lot
of like GCP operators such as they run
big query query operator so many
different operators are there once
you've done was the import then you put
all your extrusion or sketching
arguments there like things like who an
owner of this workflow you know how
often do you want to run when do you
want to start a workflow when you honor
and the workflow so on and so forth
and once we have once you have the
argument set up then right in the
workflow itself is actually really
straightforward with a top-level
dietician then you can specify your task
you know any task that's that you plan
to contain in that workflow so the as I
mention in this example we use bash
operator that you can in fact use any
operator and the nice thing really about
elf law is it has the flexibility for
you to introduce your operator this is
really you know time got tying back to
my early point about managing complexity
you know be able to come up with higher
level abstractions and be
able to hide that complicity form your
internet users is really one way for us
to navigate this complex sort of
workspace once you put everything
together
you submitted two o'clock composure from
that point onwards composure will take
care of scheduling running and
monitoring your flows this is a sort of
like a typical - like you know web UI
for you to access your work flow from
there you will be able to inspect that
you know the graphics structure if you
workflow and also you will be able to
inspect different locks you know what
come when it comes to individual tasks
they also have like a very rich set of
dashboarding for you to inspect you know
if you put all your tasks runs back what
slow runs together how does the
processing time flash race across
different time runs sometimes that helps
you to detect anomalies in your workflow
behind the scene this is what happens
you know Composer
Krays are a collection of GCP resources
and then leveraging those resources with
joinery those resources are collectively
known as cloud composing environment and
then within that environment we host
like you know our flow scheduler worker
web server the database and then the
workflow storage the same workflow
storage is also used to for you to store
workflow artifacts and then once you
have your tags there then you will be
able to orchestrate and connect to a
whole set of external systems earlier I
should share really a simple example but
then really a diet can be as complicated
as this although the graffiti self looks
complicated but actually the code to
behind a graph isn't that hard so this
is the I just want to say that this is a
real tag we use within the clock
composer team to sort of dynamically
generate outflow talking images that's
so far about you know a quick overview
of composer and airflow next I'll hand
over to Daniel to talk about compose a
pandora's moved to Clarks composer a
good morning
is Daniel Barrett I'm a staff engineer
at Pandora I'm here to talk today about
our moved to GCP with a cloud composer
from on prime air flow just to give a
little history on scheduling at Pandora
originally when I started we had a
system of legacy Java schedulers they
were based in Java they used the courts
framework as the actual scheduler they
were completely developed in-house so
because they're developed in-house it
was very hard for engineers analysts
outside of analytics to create jobs in
the framework there wasn't a whole lot
of online support either it was all
based off of whatever we documented
internally it had a limited UI that we
developed ourselves if you wanted to add
new features we had to go out and
develop them ourselves that also took
place you know when you're doing other
work and other tasks so a lot of times
it did and you know it was very slow to
be developed in the UI about two years
ago we started our migration to airflow
the airflow UI is full of features and
incredibly easy to use it has support as
things showed you for various
technologies within Google Cloud and
then also you know regular technologies
that allow you to integrate with hive
and Hadoop and things like that that we
use to do our analytics processing it
has a very large online support
community if you run into any problems
it's very easy to be able to google it
and look at look it up and somebody else
is probably run into that same problem
and will allow you to be able to figure
out you know a solution to your problem
it is all written in Python and is
incredibly easy to develop new operators
and sensors that will do custom tasks
for you things that you do over and over
and over again you can put those into
operators and allow other developers to
use them much much more simply and not
have to reinvent the wheel every time
because it was open source and there was
a large community behind it it was very
easy to onboard new engineers that had
experience using air flow it was not a
lot of ramped up time in our previous
one there was quite a bit of ramped up
time and a period where people were
getting used to the the legacy Java
scheduler
that didn't have to happen in airflow
there was another issue that we came
across and a lot of our analysts at
Pandora would use cron to be able to
schedule their hive scripts in the past
this obviously is not a great solution
and it was very easy for us to be able
to integrate the analysts to create air
flow tasks and jobs that could depend on
other jobs and things of that nature
that made it much more simpler and and
robust than just running a cron script
using hive we were also able to use a
sensor to depend on other analytics jobs
completion outside of your actual
airflow instance on Prem after those two
years now we have approximately about 90
instances between development and
production in Pandora air flow has been
adopted very widely and very quickly so
there are five problems that we looked
at that we had to solve when we moved
from air flow to composure one of them
was during the the migration composer
and air flow are both running in cloud
nam prem and the issues between running
them in two locations it was also the
question of how do we depend on a job
finishing in either location and then
composer is a true distributed framework
on prem we made the decision to deploy
composer to a single a single vm so that
it was a lot simpler for the deployments
so that we did not have to manage a
distributed deployment of air flow on
Prem and then how do we support analysts
in creating jobs that run on data proc
back on Prem they were used to having a
Hadoop cluster that was always on that
they could submit jobs to anytime now
they had to figure out how to actually
run stuff on data proc itself and then
finally how do we deploy code to
composer from a non-print bitbucket or a
repository on Prem so the first one that
we solved was the job dependency
solution so for that we have a Postgres
database on Prem of
we'll move that to the cloud and there
is a meta service rest api container
that sits in front of that Postgres
database that handles requests for jobs
or tables that are finished or you know
code that is asking you know is
something finished for the day
so that allows jobs or tables to be
consent as complete for a specific day
parameter it would also allow you to get
the status of a job or table for a very
specific day and so around that we
created an airflow sensor that would ask
the meta service if a dependency is
fulfilled if you have if you are
depending on job X you would create that
sensor in your workflow and it would say
you know it is a job X done for you know
April 1st of 2019 and then on the
flipside we also created an operator
that at the end of the airflow workflow
you could set your dependency is
complete your table your job whatever it
is that you or you were running so this
is what that looks like you know from
the architecture and here we have two
composer instances that are running in
GCP and two airflow on Prem there is the
meta service with the Postgres service
Postgres database backing it so for this
instance we would have a job populating
a table running on composer instance
number one that job the several jobs
that are waiting on that table to be
done on composer instance number two and
on Prem three and four after the table
is populated in composer one it would
send a status done to that meta service
in that post cross API I'm sorry that
Postgres database and then the meta
service would then tell two three and
four that that job is now complete and
then their workflows will be able to
move on from there there are a couple of
approach drawbacks to this in DCP one is
that because we are Postgres instances
on Prem and because we have on Prem
instances it is required that we need a
BPC network for our composer instances
in GCP so currently with due to our
networking model that we decided in DCP
we
you know we had we use shared V pcs and
currently you can only have one shared V
PC network / composer instance so in a
specific project that means that we can
only have one composer instance that
uses that job dependency framework and
also if you have a table that needs
historical and for some reason it
happened before we set up the framework
and that job does those tables with
those jobs are not done in that
framework then we needed some kind of
dependency override to be able to
process history where the dependencies
are not set in the past so the next
problem we do is dealing with celery so
celery is the asynchronous task queue
job scheduler used as the workers in
composer and it has some drawbacks so
specifically I had a job that it was a
scientists job that had three pipelines
that were highly paralyzed that we were
going to move to GCP last year so I took
these pipelines and I knew that it had
three distinct parts and I ran them
manually on a specific machines to
determine what type of machine could
handle each individual task from that I
determined the actual machine type that
I was going to use to handle these
pipelines so originally what I did is I
set up composer with three worker nodes
with the very specific machine type that
I knew I wanted to be able to handle
this task was an n1 standard 16 16 cores
when it came to actually scheduling
those tasks the celery scheduler calls
those nodes to be overwhelmed because
what it would do is it would actually
schedule two tasks on one node and one
task on another node and then nothing on
the third node it was not an even
scheduling of tasks itself and because
my node type couldn't handle more than
one of the pipeline's you know it would
cause it to freeze so this is what it
looked like when it would actually
execute you would have the scheduler it
would execute one of them on worker one
two of them on worker two and nothing
running on worker three so the solution
that I'd used to get around this is I
created three BM instances of the type
of machine that I wanted to
and I named them processor one two and
three and then I shut those machine
instances down I then set up composer
with three normal notes and one standard
four and then I set up the composer DAG
to use to use those processor machines
and what I would do is my task would SCP
fresh code from composer over to the
processor machines themselves and then
it would use an SSH command to run the
pipeline on each individual instance so
this enabled the actual processing to
happen on the processing machines and
not on the composer nodes itself so what
would happen there is my scheduler would
schedule on worker 1 and 2 on worker 2
but then those workers would actually
execute the code on the actual process
of machines themselves so I ended up
with one task running on one one test
running on two and one test running on
three this is enabled the the process to
happen the way that I actually wanted it
to happen at the end of the processing
when everything was done I would then
shut down processor one two and three so
you're no longer getting charged for
those to use those nodes this is what
the resulting dag looked like if you
look at the very beginning you'll see a
start VM instances tasks this is where I
would start up processor one two and
three and then I would wait for those
instances to fully start up I then had
task 2 SCP the code over to each one of
those VM instances and then I would run
the scripts and then it would have a
couple of different tasks that would do
some other processing and some local
data cleanup on each one of those VM
instances and then at the very end you
see at the very last one I would stop
all three of those VM instances because
we don't need them running until they're
ready to go the next day so the next
problem we had to look at was how do we
make data proc easier for analysts to
use analysts are like I said before
they're used to having a Hadoop cluster
that is always on and accepts their jobs
at any time they may have to wait for
resources but they could just fire off
queries and fire
off tasks and send them to this Hadoop
cluster data prophet is a little bit
different than that data proc you have
to know a little bit to be able to
create a data proc instance you have to
understand it a little bit more water
worker nodes and some of the the
properties that are needed to start up a
data proc instance so like I said it was
a bar to entry for analysts to use the
data proc to run their scheduled queries
so what we ended up developing was a
batch job framework and this was
developed with a Google contractor
called new dezik this was a batch job
framework that requires minimal coding
and really not hardly any data proc
knowledge whatsoever
it would require them to create config
files that just defined their sequel the
sequel tasks that they had and the
variables that we're going to be put
into the sequel tasks and then the dag
was dynamically configured from those
config files themselves the config files
will define external and interact
dependencies sensors based off of other
jobs that were running on other airflow
instances on Prem the piece that I
showed you earlier you would define
those in the config files for your
sequel and you would also define inside
of the dag what config what
sequel files depended on other ones so
that they could then be set up correctly
in a dag it would also provide a way to
instantiate a data proc cluster for each
sequel statement run using only the
number of workers needed and to do this
there was a heavy use of data fraud data
product war flow templates the data proc
workflow templates would start up the
cluster for the for the batch job they
would run the sequel file on that
cluster and then they would delete that
cluster afterwards and we found that
this was the best way to use data proc
it was repeatable and was less prone to
error than some of the other ways that
we looked at running data product and
running sequel files on data proc this
is all the code that was required to be
able to create this dynamic dag
dag so this create batch dag
operator was what actually went through
all of the config files and constructed
the dag itself this code can be copied
from one project to the next one
so the analyst would not really need to
know any Python whatsoever in order to
run their batch jobs this could be hi
this could be spark and several of the
different ways of running stuff from
that code came this dag right here
so this dag was created using that code
using config files that were set up for
it like I said it was a minimal amount
of code to be able to create something
as complex as this this is our one of
our largest jobs called on nightly job
and it it's a great name but there's a
lot of you'll see on the left are all of
our external sensors that were other
jobs on other airflow or imports or
things like that that we were waiting on
to be complete in order for our process
to start each one of those pieces would
have there would be data quality checks
involved in that where after the table
was completely loaded it would do
duplicate checks or threshold checks or
things of that nature so that you were
ensured that your data was you know up
to your standards at the end of the
process and then at the very end it
would set its status is complete for
each individual table back in our
analytics Postgres database and allow
other jobs to be kicked off from that so
one of the other ones was how do we
deploy code from on-premise Pandora to
composer in the cloud so the ways that
we came up with to deploy one of them
would be an on-prem Jenkins build that
uses a plugin that Google has for
Jenkins to be able to push code to a
composer dag bucket all of your code in
composer is synced to a bucket so
whenever you create a composer instance
there is a composer bucket that is
assigned to that instance inside there
there is a tags folder and also a
plugins folder these are the two places
that you need to deploy your code in
order to run them in composer you can
also just drag and drop manually into
the composer bucket using Google's
console UI that is a very simple way but
it also a manual
so the other one would be more of an
automated build the second one would be
more of a manual process but something
we came up with a Pandora because a lot
of our analysts are not really used to
command-line performance and so we came
up with a view that would allow them to
use a webpage to sync a project from big
bucket this view looks like this and
this view when you pulled it up would go
out to our internal bit bucket repo and
it will pull all of the publicly the
internal topango are publicly available
bitbucket repositories you could select
which one you wanted you could select
the branch you wanted and then
individually you could select the commit
that you wanted and then when you push
submit it would sink that code to the
DAGs folder on the server that it was
running on on Pandora so we had to take
this and move it to composer to be able
to do the same kind of thing so on Prem
the view would build to get command and
then sync directly to the file system
because it would run the gate command on
as an external process in python on
composer the web server is not running
on the kubernetes composer cluster so
the web server doesn't have access to
the file system where your DAGs are
located or the data directory that
you're allowed to do working on composer
is located so we had to think of it a
little bit differently way and we had to
create a dag to take care of any web
server action and send send the dag
arguments from the web server itself
that is because of this this composer
architecture right here
you'll see that the workers the Redis
the airflow scheduler and the cloud
sequel proxy are all running on the
kubernetes engine but the airflow web
server is running on the tenant project
right so it did not have access to the
file system on the kubernetes cluster
itself the downsides to a dag sink or
the composer bucket is synced down to
the container file system but not back
up so you could not just sync the code
to the actual local file system where
the DAGs are located because it would be
overwritten the next time that google
synced your code from the bucket down to
the file system itself another one is
that bit bucket projects must be made
public within the organization and
in order to view them to pull a list of
them pulls because of the network from
on-prem bitbucket are a little slow and
this is to be expected because you're
pulling them up to Google Composer you
have to sync the project code to home
air flow GCS data before doing an AR
sync up to the composer bucket the home
airflow GCS data was just the temporary
location in order to sync the code there
so we did not have to overwrite
everything in the bucket every time that
we wanted to do a pull from from
bitbucket and that is it for me um and I
will hand you over hi everybody I'm
Wilson Lin I'm a software engineer on
the cloud composer team and today I have
the privilege of telling you all about
some new features that we've rolled out
recently and composer so something that
we've heard a lot from our customers is
how can I monitor my environments to
make sure that they're up and running
and healthy and making progress on DAGs
as well as determine whether or not I've
provisioned enough resources for my
environment to make progress or sorry to
handle the workload that I'm throwing at
it and so to answer that question our
the composer data plane is now exporting
metrics into stackdriver as you can see
here we're exporting information about
the quantity and latency of both dag
runs and tasks instances so you can see
if anything has gotten stuck
we're also exporting information about
the health of the celery cue including
the number of celery workers that are up
and the length of the queue now let's
flip over to the demo screen and I'll
show you how you can use these metrics
okay so you can see here I've built this
dashboard earlier basically we're
showing on the Left column the number of
DAG runs and tasks runs per ton over
time and on the right column we have the
latency of DAG runs and task runs over
time so if we zoom in on a one hour we
can see that we have four dag runs per
hour for a single particular dag called
sometimes slow and we can see in the on
the right-hand side that the latency of
that
background varies over the course of an
hour in fact once every hour it takes
much longer than the other dag runs in
that hour and if we look down at the
tasks we happen I happen to know that
the this dag has two tasks one of them
is called consistent one it's a bash
operator and it runs fairly consistently
and the other one is called sometimes
slow and it's Python operator and I
queued for this demo and I made it so
that sometimes slow checks the time and
once an hour makes itself one minute
slower than every other time that it
runs but so this is a bit of a contrived
example but you can see how if you had
some external dependency that was
introducing latency into your diagrams
you would be able to see this in a
secretary monitoring console and
additionally you could go in and create
a an alerting policy and let's do that
right now we'll create an alert so that
whenever that that task is slow we get
an email so we'll filter that by the
task name and say whenever sometimes
slow is takes longer than 60 seconds we
will for one minute we will get an email
or some other notification this is just
a standard stack of our monitoring stuff
and then we can save that and likewise
we could do a similar thing for the for
the celery queue of normally a celery
queue length of 0 is a good sign that
means that your workers are able to keep
up with the offered load so we could set
up an alert on the seller queue and
whenever it exceeds some threshold we
can get an alert and realize that we
need to do some reprovision ting so now
let's swap back to the slides please
so the next feature that I'm going to
talk about is one that you can use to
help improve the security of your clock
composer environments so whenever you
create a clock composer environment as
then pointed out the clock composer
control plane is going to create a gke
cluster and cloud sequel instance for
you and by default the
for the those uh for the gk cluster and
cloud sequel instance will have public
IPS meaning that they are externally
routable and you can be reached from
anyone on the Internet
moreover the communication to your
airflow database in the cloud sequel
instance will traverse the public
Internet
so what this means is your traffic
potentially traverses the public
Internet and if you have say a zero-day
vulnerability and some demon running on
your system
it could be exploited by someone on the
internet however with private IP
clusters we only assign an internal non
publicly routable IP addresses to all of
your gke VMs and they cloud sequel
instance vm optionally you can enable a
feature which will put the kubernetes
master for your g key cluster behind a
private only IP as well so let's swap
back to the demo screen and i'll show
you how you can create this you can you
can do this using the beta channel of
the G cloud tool but you can also do
this in club in the GCP console by
enabling beta features up in the top
right corner let's just look at what a
private IP cluster looks like okay so
I've recreated this I peek a private IP
cluster earlier you can see that a
private environment is set to true and I
have master master external access at
the false so the kubernetes master
should only have a an internal IP so if
we drill down into the GAE cluster
that's associated with this we can see
that the master endpoint has an IP
address 170 to 1602 which is an internal
IP address and if we look at the node
pool to check out the G GCE VMs that
were allocated for this we can see that
they have no external Ike peace the last
feature that I like to touch on is one
that we've been we've been working on
for a long time and basically let's say
you're really excited when you get out
of here to go and try out this secretary
monitoring feature or some of the new
features that you've seen us announce
and recent releases in the past we would
have asked you to create a new
environment and then move all your DAGs
over and then move all your airflow meta
data over to the new environment and
then take down the old environment
now with just the push of a button you
can upgrade your environments in place
and preserve the vm's the cloud sequel
instance and all your airflow metadata
on the same environment while still
running the latest version of composer
or even an upgraded version of airflow I
can try to demo this but I will see if
we're able to to try that let's go back
at the demo screen so I have this
environment here that's ready to be
upgraded I've enabled beta features and
we can see that it's running composer
1.30 and airflow 1 high note so if we
just hit the upgrade image version
button we can select the new image
version 1.6 step one is our most recent
version and let's upgrade to the latest
version of airflow submit and then the
upgrades is in flight it'll complete in
a few minutes and then you'll be at the
latest version that's all the all I have
for more information on click composer
or airflow you can check out these links
[Music]